yeah but what's your relationship with
Chris Cuomo what do you think about
Chris I like Chris and so I get heat for
liking Chris but I like Chris you know
why I like him why is that because he's
open-minded and so he actually is more a
lot more establishment Democrat than I
am we disagree on a lot of the policies
Etc and I his brother I can't stand uh
but but Chris is the only guy who ever
had progressives on his show in cable
news no one else ever has progressives
like you like you're a likable guy in
person
he'll have everybody yeah he's
enormously check when you say you don't
like his brother what's the oh Andrew
Cuomo's the definition of a corrupt
establishment Democrat I mean you give
him any kind of money he'll do you any
favor and the real estate interests in
New York totally owns Andrew Cuomo
Andrew Cuomo uh took out Progressive
after Progressive in New York put in he
purposely reduced the power of the
democratic party uh did a splinter group
the group that he authorized to pretend
that they had to share power with
Republicans so we could do is donor's
bidding like no one does the donor's
bidding better than Andrew Cuomo that's
why when Trump uh in the beginning if
you remember before Joe Biden before
anyone else before Andrew Cuomo ran into
trouble all of the Liberals like the
establishment Democrats were like oh
yeah Andrew Cuomo Andrew Cuomo's doing
so good with Coleman yeah Andrew Coleman
Andrew coma why whenever you see a lot
of people talking in the Press about
positively about one guy that is almost
always propaganda like oh and here's how
you know Biden might be on his way out
all of a sudden a glowing piece in one
of the uh I forget if it was Vanity Fair
one of the other pieces article
magazines about Gretchen Whitmer out of
nowhere the governor of Michigan yeah
and all of a sudden she's Our Savior I'm
like why do we need saving and then
gavinusums all over TV you know what
that means they're getting the Cavalry
ready because by look Biden as they
should though and they should because
look my number one problem with buying
isn't how conservative he is it's minor
is it just me is it a little hot in here
okay can we crank up the age see because
I'm trying to see if the okay go for it
so now my number two problem with Biden
is the that he's a corporatist he's a
liar it's all that stuff my number one
problem with him is he's gonna lose like
we're playing with fire we talked about
it with Oppenheimer so if Trump is as
bad as I think he is would I want to run
a super weak old man who doesn't even
want to campaign against him yeah a guy
whose popularity is oftentimes in the
30s here's a giant lie of the mainstream
meter only Joe Biden can beat Donald
Trump wait why first of all tons of
people can beat Donald Trump Donald
Trump's in the 30s an approval rating uh
Jim jablowski can be Donald Trump
the only people who can't beat Donald
Trump are establishment Democrats who
are deeply unpopular because they're
fakes and they're phonies right so they
say oh Biden beat him last time he beat
him by 43 000 votes in three swing
States it doesn't matter how much he won
the popular vote by he the Electoral
College he only won by the skid of his
teeth and he was 15 points higher at
that point the Democrats are walking
into a Slaughter with their eyes wide
open and saying I would rather lose to
Trump than have a progress so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]